c'est quand est-ce qu'on démarre dans
quoi je suis
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai qu'à moi si le patient
est habillée comme ça j'espère juste
trouver un travail très vite compliqué
merci
[Rires]
[Musique]
où
oh
côté de nice j'ai du mal à me faisais
pas trop lâché soir la grande dans le
cas c'est lui tape pourra s'éclater
bien sûr cela nouvelles viennent
d'arriver à ce que le fait de s aggraver
leur sagesse avalanche salon
[Musique]
tu parles physique se dit ah la la
bla bla [ __ ] up la vie voilà voilà qui
tranche et
voilà oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
nathan mélomanes ont ils fait
[Musique]
celui animé c'est le pire c'est la voie
que celle là
[Musique]
la magie
l'agrément et la vie voilà
[Musique]